dans ces territoires libérés la joie
s'affiche sur les visages mais derrière
les sourires se cachent une réalité plus
sombre celle des crimes commis par les
troupes russes durant l'occupation
commencer en mars dans ce bois 17 civils
de la défense territoriale ont perdu la
vie face au temps crusse leur cadavres
ont été abandonnés
et tous les gars étaient morts ils
n'avaient pas d'armes automatiques juste
des cocktails Molotov
ils sont allés au combat avec rien de
plus que ça
pour les autorités ukrainiennes il
s'agit bien d'un crime de guerre
se trouvait des civils qui ne faisaient
pas partie des forces armées de
l'Ukraine en réalité c'était juste des
civils ordinaires de notre ville
l'Ukraine veut attirer l'attention du
monde entier sur ses événements en
ouvrant un accès encadré à la presse la
police nous a escorté dans un centre de
détention ou des civils et des soldats
se faisaient torturer
il criait toutes les nuits quand je m'en
souviens j'ai peur même maintenant
des conditions de détention terrible
cet ancien prisonnier nous raconte
oreilles
parfois on peut s'habituer à un type de
torture mais ces animaux ont toujours
inventé de nouveaux types de techniques
les habitants parlent de corps entassés
dans des véhicules de ramassage des
ordures certains survivants ont été
embarqués par des forces russes après
leur retrait personne ne sait ce qu'ils
sont devenus
plus que jamais l'Ukraine espère un
soutien
nous espérons que nos partenaires
internationaux nous aideront dans les
tribunaux internationaux à inculper non
seulement les commandants supérieurs et
les généraux de la Fédération de Russie
mais chaque soldat est citoyen russe qui
est coupable de crimes de guerre contre
les Ukrainiens
la Russie accuse l'Ukraine de mettre en
scène ses événements pourtant du côté de
Carson les preuves continue de
s'accumuler